[Applause]
well you know
the pentagon just uh put out a press
release i don't know if you saw this but
they
they've uh officially the government has
acknowledged that ufos exist
did you see that i ain't gonna laugh i
believe that
aliens haircut i like this [ __ ] i
already heard
oh no i think so too but i'm just
curious like if the uh the thought of
aliens being real
kind of [ __ ] up the premise of a lot of
religions being real
i think somebody some of you [ __ ] i'm
saying some of them [ __ ] they put on
the tv
as well like who man i need an example
i'm trying to look out for these aliens
you feel me bro
you mean to me elon musk's not an alien
yo
that's the bro it's funny you said elon
musk
he's the only person that in my head
i've thought to myself
if anyone's a [ __ ] alien it's that
weird [ __ ] elon
come on bro he's trying to get people to
go to mars
well you know he's trying to install uh
he's got a uh
a a company called euro uh neurologic
yeah right and what they're doing in san
francisco is they're developing
technology
where they cut a piece of your skull out
of your head and they install a chip
and the chip meshes with your brain so
that's
like and this is where you [ __ ] with god
creation at this point
that's what when i heard that i'm like
yo elon musk's on some other [ __ ] bro
you got some cute cars and [ __ ] but that
[ __ ] is crazy you don't like that
they like the raw g
yeah i think uh i think would like if
that becomes the normal in the future
would you get a chip put in your brain
hell no hey you don't know
yeah you're going to be living in a
technology
no dude i wouldn't but that ain't
no yeah i think i think elon musk could
be an alien i mean if i had to bet on
anyone being an alien
he'd he's definitely the favorite for
sure he's like the lakers in the
playoffs they got to be the favorite
right now
you know what i'm saying elon's got to
be the alien either him or maybe sean
hannity or somebody like that
because you can't say you can't bruh you
can't
look food if a [ __ ] come to my face
and say hey man let's move to mars let's
move to mars let's move to mars
he said i've been there his head and
lived there before you like no
[ __ ] way
your way just want to say let go to mars
and we feel the live on
[ __ ] first off they say as hot as hell
there so we ain't gonna be thinking
about going there
[ __ ] let's go to mars the [ __ ]
you know been there before this little
boy i'm not
gonna push it in my brain nothing's
going in your brain will you even drive
a tesla
because i [ __ ] with that tesla truck
that they put out i'm trying to get that
thing but i don't know man it could be a
trap you feel me this [ __ ] kind of
police
the tesla's kind of the police it kind
of is [ __ ] police phone
the [ __ ] computer's in the middle of
your car lord knows where to get
recorded these phones out and [ __ ] alexa
oh this [ __ ] you gotta you got the alexa
at the crib
like that you know but sometimes when i
be saying certain [ __ ] my siri come on
yeah yeah that's crazy
i mean i guess there's a lot of stuff we
could dive into with that but
[ __ ] all that